ce ne sera pas une guerre de héros qui
est tout à voir cela va être amusant
le monde brûle vous n'avez aucune idée de ce dont les
hommes sont capables nous devons faire quelque chose
je sais que vous voulez vous battre
mais il y a d'autres façons de faire votre
Devoir, vous allez avoir besoin d'un costume, allez,
nous sommes les premières
agences de renseignement indépendantes à préserver la paix
et à protéger la vie pendant que le gouvernement
attend les
ordres.
nos ennemis pensent que nous sommes des hommes doux
mais la réputation est ce que les gens pensent de
vous le
caractère est ce que vous êtes
armé et prêt ouais
mais prêt nous verrons
cela s'appelle un parachute cela signifie que l'
on peut sauter d'un avion en toute sécurité
vous